come siete arrivati
stamattina
seduti questa platea sicuramente c'è
qualcuno che è arrivato con le i mezzi
pubblici
qualcuno con la propria auto e qualcun
altro a piedi ha compiuto una scelta un
po dettata anche dalle dal meteo bene
basta
così banale su si è una persona in
carrozzina
ad esempio come lei è una scelta
importante con un proprio peso perché
quello sì è una persona in carrozzina
le nostre azioni losco pensiero solo
molto spesso legati all andata doppio
con
le altre persone con quello che generano
le altre persone
fare compiere una scelta così di uso
quotidiano spesso è complicato ma
giriamoci per un attimo anche voi di
essere seduti in carrozzina e di
muovervi in un bollo
ipotetico e molte azioni che compiamo
possono subire grossi cambiamenti
tesseva di esempio quando proviamo
qualche persona che parcheggia l'auto a
ridosso dell'assoluto nella discesa di
un marciapiedi pensiamo ad esempio
quando fanno il mondo sul marciapiede
incontriamo delle biciclette abbandonate
in qualche modo o ancora ad esempio alla
raccolta differenziata
una situazione così importante per il
nostro volo per il delle ossa le loro
mondo è così limitante per il mondo di
qualcun altro e quelli ci troviamo ora i
colpi con le diversità le diversita
della vita le diversita di crociera di
visuale di pensiero critico
ci proviamo quindi a zero sono i conti
con una parola io sono certa che per il
93 cerca di voi è una grossa novità
la parola era venissimo
a finirlo l'angelo che voi pensiate che
sia qualcosa di meraviglioso e avviati a
fare con un'enfasi di abilità di fare
cose bene l'avviso è la cosa più brutta
che possa esistere e che possa essere
alimentata da noi e dalla nostra società
la fiducia non è che una forma di
discriminazione
razziale molto grave alzare dello
razzismo e dello sco la virgo è la
considerazione che le persone hanno di
avere a che fare sempre con un corpo
influì ordine
l'avviso è quella situazione che lette
il divario 10 sono
secondi crismi ad esempio della società
per rispetto ad un altro che magari
alieni lì che definisco quindi va
combattuto perché
essendo una forma di discriminazione
vuol dire mettere il secondo piano
l'importanza di un'altra persona
e noi non ci possiamo permettere di
decidere a priori questo nemmeno sa la
società a darci questo lo è a darci
questa abitudine è su questo che noi lo
devo combattere la dobbiamo anche sapere
cosa vuol dire e qual è la sua
la luce
l'importanza della società latinismo a
due forme conclamate la bellusco può
essere attivo e può essere passivo la di
riso attivo è tutto ciò che riguarda la
comunicazione
non verbale
la gestualità ciò che noi abbiamo
compiere con le azione nei confronti
delle altre persone mentre l'abilissimo
passivo è quello che riusciamo più a
combattere se vogliamo
ed è anche quello più di uso quotidiano
e il fido delle parole e l'importanza
del linguaggio che noi andiamo ad
utilizzare in qualsiasi forma di
comunicazione scritta ed orale
lo devo imparare ad ater assessore con
il tema della diversità hanno rimbalzo
norci davanti all'immagine che lo
rappresenta secondo lui e sottolineo
secondo lui la giusta importanza di
essere definito persone
dobbiamo smettere quindi di dare alle
persone
un'etichetta di scarico e soprattutto
imparare ad utilizzare le parole con il
giusto peso scegliendo quelle misure
quelle giuste misure però non mettere le
persone in difficoltà e lo stelo
minoranza
è importante sapere e conoscere il tema
della diversità per scegliere quelli
migliori e ad esempio l'anno le loro lì
solo per la rossa l'anno senza negarvi
qualche consiglio è giusto non fare leva
sulla persona
disabile usando proprio queste parole
che le tiene in primo piano ciò che
lancia rispetto ciò che ho il limite che
ha rispetto quello che può fare è giusto
dimenticare
tutto ciò che riguarda l'aspetto
solitario la malattia luce fa dobbiamo
nascondere ciò che siamo l'attrice non è
quello che caratterizza ciò che siamo e
la cosa più facile forse da vedere
lasciamo diverso l'ente abile lasciamo
anni fatato lasciamo mongoloide anche
solo tra scherzare con qualcun altro
informiamo per una volta ad essere
consapevoli che davanti abbiamo una
persona con una sfumatura diverso nello
sfondo e quindi la cosa più giusta da
dire è però sola con disabilità
al di là del linguaggio e la cosa più
facile sulla quale possiamo combattere
per migliorare perché mi sento di dire
che è proprio una battaglia ma abbiamo
le giuste armi in mano per partono dalla
vittoria basta volerlo
abbiamo anche la ville il suo attivo che
lo legale con secondo piano perché le
loro selezioni l'uno porto a più persone
l'ho raccolto le comunicazioni più
persone è determinante del saggio che
vogliamo dare è giusto l'esempio
rispettare la persona con disabilità per
ciò che rappresenta professionalmente
tre giochi e rappresenta con un nome e
un cognome
non andare a toccare quello che può
essere il suo ausilio della vita comune
nel mio caso mi da molto fastidio quando
qualcuno si prende l'onere di spostare
la mia carrozzina certo per aiutarmi in
questo modo tu agisci sulla mia libertà
e la mia autonomia fine pro montare le
cose anche perché nel momento in cui tu
vai a giocare una persona non sai ad
abbattere la confidenza e non vajenti a
prenderti quella confidenza
vale adesso una persona il educato e
rispettoso di ciò che quella persona
rappresenta
e viene però anche dirvi che purtroppo
le persone avvenisse non solo quelle
solo quelle loro giocate c'è un'altra
parola che io adoro perché credo che la
diversità per decretare un lato a e lato
b le loro società però è giusto per
farvi capire che
le persone abili se siamo anche noi
persone con disabilità che pure di non
sentirsi un peso per questa società
tendiamo sempre all'elementare ciò che
offriamo è ciò che rappresentiamo tanto
da farci diventare per questa società
una categoria
marginalizzata una nicchia una nicchia
che però è ora che abbia voce in
capitolo per un altro segreto
la disabilità lo riguarda solo le
persone che già si trovano in una
condizione lo riguarda solo le persone
con una disabilità full time come la mia
ad esempio della logica la la disabilità
riguarda tutti noi prima o poi nella
vita pensavo di esempio a chi c'era un
suo braccio una causa per cui nei
workshop e disabili tanto quanto me e
voi avete quasi stessi ai bisogni ogni è
giusto far entrare nel nostro giardino
questa tematica perché prima o poi
avremo a che fare con il mondo della
disabilità
sono certa che cui oggi vi ha dato
un po di novità mi ha fatto uscire da
quella che è la quotidianità e
l'abitudine che abbiamo per relazionarci
con una tematica che fosse pensiamo non
ci appartenga bene non voglio che ci
vuole tutti uguali e ci vuole universali
io credo invece sia giusto pensare che
al mondo sul cielo persone diverse e
prendere lui tanto di esempio come
fossero eroi conclamati perché vedete
che dietro di me non c'è nessun mantello
line giusto persone consapevoli che le
riconosciuto di ogni persona chi più
utile lo è più visibile o meno visibile
devono essere un punto di partenza per
invertire la rotta di questa società che
va troppo veloce e lo dà più tempo di
ascoltare le persone lo soprattutto è
giusto che ha preso il suo posto sconto
voi
siate consapevoli che la diversità di
una persona potrebbe essere il fulcro di
partenza di una nuova forma di
comunicazione e di dialogo che va a
finire nella parola futuro
[Applauso]